the anger from those students and
parents in South Florida echoed around
the country thousands of students from
Washington State to Washington DC walked
out of school yesterday demanding
stricter gun control laws more than a
thousand people rallied outside the
State Capitol in Tallahassee Florida
while students from Stoneman Douglas
high lobbied their state lawmakers
Adriana Diaz is in Tallahassee with that
part of the story Adrianna good morning
good morning we sat in three of those
meetings between students and lawmakers
and the teenagers asked them pointed
questions about their positions on
assault rifles and school security that
group arrived early this morning back in
parkland by bus and in their short time
here they made sure their message was
heard Florida State Capitol became the
nerve center of a growing nationwide
movement to end gun violence there's a
lot of talk about looking when are you
gonna actually do any action you have
started something inside survivors of
last week's shooting held meetings with
lawmakers including Democrats Severin
Jones you have my solid word that I will
fight to make sure that we get something
in their face to make them enforceable I
mean that answers from other legislators
like Republican Senate President Joe
Negron weren't as decisive an ar-15
which was constructed to kill it's a
military weapon it's not meant for
self-defense students were not deterred
we are coming after you we are coming
after every single one of you and
demanding that you take action demanding
that you make a change by noon more than
a thousand protesters converged outside
the Capitol raising the volume on their
demands solidarity was displayed
nationwide with staged walkouts lions
and marches from Maryland some sort of
common-sense gun control legislation
needs to be passed into law because far
too many innocent people have been
killed
- Minnesota marching because we students
deserve to feel safe in our schools
state lawmakers on both sides of the
aisle are working on legislation that
would increase funding for mental health
in schools and limit access to assault
rifles but not ban them the sheriff in
Broward County where parkland is
announced that going forward deputies
will be armed with rifles at County
schools John
adrianna of thanks